this will turn our detention into a
death sentence in 2020 as the kovid 19
pandemic raged migrants in u.s
government detention facilities in
california protested and went to court
over dangerous conditions in a final
settlement reached late last month the
federal immigration enforcement agency
ice and private for-profit prison
corporations agreed to safety
protections for detainees including
coveted vaccinations and limits on
detainee populations
unsanitary conditions and indifferent
guards at a rural county jail under
contract with ice were experienced by
immigration detainee and asylum seeker
joe mejia there was feces and uh urine
and and it was just bad situation and it
was really hard for us to get cleaning
supplies we'd see some of the guards
would come in and they'd be sick they'd
have a cold and next you know they'd be
gone for two three weeks
and
we've come to find out that some of the
guards were actually infected with kovid
and they weren't taking any precautions
to help us out or keep us safe the
american civil liberties union won a
ruling that freed hundreds of detainees
while awaiting asylum hearings we filed
the lawsuit because it was clear from
the outset that when kobit began to
spread ice and geo group it's its
private for-profit contractor
were putting people at great risk of
serious harm and death
geo group is contracted by ice to hold
detainees it runs more than 100 prisons
processing centers and other facilities
last year president joe biden issued an
order phasing out contracts between the
justice department and private
for-profit prisons but that order didn't
cover immigrant detainees we've been
deeply disappointed by how things have
played out throughout his campaign biden
promised to end the use of for-profit
detention by the federal government
including for undocumented immigrants
and this would have a huge impact on the
ice detention system of course because
uh nearly 80 percent of people who are
in ice detention are in facilities that
are privately operated
as large numbers of migrants are
expected at the u.s mexico border in the
coming months the biden administration
informed congress this week it will use
a home curfew program as an alternative
to incarceration
now awaiting an asylum hearing mejia
cannot forget how he was treated in
detention we were
you know just treated worse than animals
you know people treat their pets way
better than what we were being treated
nearly 21 000 migrants are currently
locked up in ice and privately run
prisons rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles